so amplitude hit the shelves on Tuesdays
this week yeah yeah I came out it's a
digital-only release so no shelves but
you can absolutely download it now that
PSN is back online digital shelves yeah
digital shells those like the metaphors
for action shots in this game although
it just came out it's this is not like
the first time we've ever played in yeah
before so this is a they're calling it a
reboot of the original amplitude so it's
based on sort of the code and the
mechanics and all that a few rich in the
game but new music new visuals all kinds
of new content so it feels extremely
reminiscent of the original game but all
kinds of new stuff to do some people may
not be familiar it's it's a rhythm game
of course that the harmonics game so
it's a rhythm game but unlike something
like rock band what's all about you know
hitting notes amplitude is more about
switching between various instruments
and keeping your streak alive by jumping
between various tracks within the same
song so it's as much about switching
swapping between various instruments as
it is about actually matching notes so
that's kind of the mechanic juggling all
these different tracks and trying to
keep everything going without breaking
your street they do added new modes and
other things that are more interesting
like there's a there's a competitive
mode and then there's like a there's a
four player up to four people and then
you can do team based company yes we
were actually sitting me playing level a
while ago so yeah you can do free for
all you can do three on one two dresses
to you yeah it's kind of interesting
there are some boosts so as with
something like rock band if you hit
certain special mark two notes you will
earn yourself a powerup basically and
they're different forms of power-ups and
some of the multiplayer specific ones
that you kind of mess with your
opponents like this one called disrupt
where you can get behind somebody on
their track and it'll make the track
kind of like start to roll and look
different and weird and it might make
them miss a node and lose their streak
also you're doin or the power-ups you
can just dive in front of somebody
before they switch to a track and if
they're behind you they can't hit notes
sorry the only front ship actually
exactly yeah the points for that so you
can kind of mess people up because if
you try to cross and somebody's in the
way they could miss their streaks you
kind of I don't know it's it's kind of
more of like a soft jab at dildo and
then actually trying to hurt yeah it's
like cutting somebody off when you're
driving or something like that you're
not actively destroying what they're
doing but you're kind of like messing
them up a little although that requires
a bit of strata you left me of looking
ahead down the track to like hit your
own
notes for the know when you can dive
over and cut somebody off and right
prevent them from getting into the next
Lane or something no there's only three
notes in this per se right yeah yeah the
middle and the right correct but again
it's all about swapping between the
different tracks or the different
highways basically so even though it's
three notes it still ends up feeling
relatively challenging especially at
higher difficulties where the notes come
at you really quickly so it's definitely
still plenty challenging even though
it's only 30 it's permanent
and because this is a music-based game I
think probably the thing every wants to
know is how much how many tracks are
there are there reminiscent tracks from
the old game end is it good yes I'm so
in the process of unlocking everything
most of the songs are locked away until
you played the campaign or played a lot
of quick play the early songs are a
little bit on the repetitive side a
little bit slower and more boring if
we're to understand some of the later
songs a little more fun but it's mainly
new songs there are a few remixes some
of the classic amplitude songs but I I
still haven't heard of it heard all of
it they're only 30 songs so it won't
take super long to unlock everything I
wish there was more I wish some of the
earlier songs a little more exciting but
I'm gonna wait and hold off completely
judging until I've heard everything the
game is to offer right and this game is
currently available for twenty bucks
yeah yep and it's available on ps3 and
ps4 you get this for pipe player mode
you get a short campaign plus free play
and 30 songs the gate and the campaign
is pretty interesting it's basically a
concept album about trying to wake a
comatose women's from liked by repairing
forebrain with music there's a story
sort I mean there's really like a
narrative but like there are loose
elements introducing each song they
could roughly tie together yeah do you
feel like you're enjoying playing it
like are you looking for a minute its a
mix of good matches the mechanics are so
really fun but I feel like the music
hasn't really grabbed me yet and given
that it is a music game that really
needs to drive the experience so until I
get a little deeper and a lot more than
music you know I can't really say but so
far it's been like it's been good good
fine hasn't totally grabbed me I was
enjoying multiplayer but I think
everyone was you know kind of over it
pretty quick so little bit as you can
see you know the game has any lunch ever
do you pass those first couple hours
right or if it's a game that you want to
play solo and really master or if it's
just like a fun party game that you play
bunch of people so far I've had more fun
solo but yeah I mean we'll see our party
was ok yeah ok party
Oh